new measures begin statewide again in
less than an hour in an effort to reduce
the coronavirus spread
local bars and restaurants will have to
limit capacity even further
and on the strip performers are taking
yet another hit as
audience capacity is reduced yet again
orco mana shares
some of the talks he had with performers
tonight and joins us now with more on
their plans to
to cope orca
denise and brian the new restrictions go
into effect just after midnight
local entertainers tell me that they're
worried the capacity limits
will impact business but they understand
combating the coronavirus
comes first it just means you know
adjusting as we can
switching things up to stop the spread
of covet 19
las vegas entertainers are gearing up
for governor sisilak's new restrictions
public gatherings will be capped at 50
people or 25 percent capacity of a venue
whichever is less this applies to shows
inside performance spaces
it's a few less tickets singer michelle
johnson tells me that the vegas room
where she's set to perform as part of an
upcoming christmas show is making
changes
in addition to already requiring masks
and strict social distancing
the venue is now only allowing 28 people
inside
i just got lucky that i'm in a show that
happens to have a small
space in the first place so we're able
to accommodate that
that reduction the show is right around
the corner from december 2nd to the 27th
but fewer seats means less money a
possible solution
is expanding the engagement by adding
performances
they can split the difference and still
you know meet their bottom line now by
the end of this video
actor and comedian john d dominico is
planning to be a part of a different
christmas show downtown but he says with
the new restrictions things are
uncertain
wow are we going to even be able to do
the show because things are just so
fluid with covid that we take two steps
forwards and
sometimes three steps back but
performers know
fighting the virus is the priority we're
in the middle of a pandemic and we've
got to stay safe
again the new restrictions under this
statewide pause begin in just
under an hour and they'll last for the
next three weeks reporting live near the
las vegas strip tonight orca mana 8 news
now
thank you orco here's a closer look at
all the changes that will kick
in after midnight restaurants and bars
can have indoor and outdoor seating
but only at twenty five percent capacity
public gatherings are limited to fifty
people
or twenty five percent capacity
whichever is less
and private gatherings are limited to
ten people from no more than two
households
masks are required everywhere indoors
and outdoors
this will last for three weeks you can
find additional details on our website